is the reject Nation we're gonna watch
One Piece episode four today Erin how
are you I am doing well and swell
fantastic my dear pal
yes hi Amigo oi leave a like on this
video and then uh after that if you want
to subscribe click the notification Bell
to get notified of a reaction for the
next episode of One Piece is up on the
Channel please go ahead and do that and
always
that doesn't make sense sure
stays in the video full length Reaction
watch along where you sync with your own
copy of One Piece available for super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
muchas gracias to all who have joined
our patreon page thus far becoming super
sexy rejects we cover several things
exclusive over there reactional lights
I can't speak today
[Music]
how did you not die from falling in a
well that deep anime physics anime
physics
it does look like completely uninjured
right he must have some kind of strength
but then again a bottle knocked him out
yeah make that make sense bottle knocked
him out yeah yeah that is an interesting
question yeah it's fine falling in the
bottom of a well
oh it's the Zorro episode oh hell yeah
that's what I'm talking about baby
Captain cool now I know you're lying my
father
Roxanne Morgan killed him years ago your
father's a joke no closer to finding the
straw hat than we were hours ago Straw
Hat you mean Luffy no goofy my other
other best friend he's in trouble too my
other best friend
dang Luffy oh it's gonna be out
incapacitated this episode and rely on
Zorro to save him oh God his throat
looks inflamed
oh my God give the necessary Exposition
for her to hear it
feels like a horror episode feels very
Tim burdening just wish I could have
asked him
now it taste it tasted like poison idiot
poison
how much of the
of the all of it oh I got that little
smile like he was a little proud of it
go ahead and toss them in the well with
a green head oath
my God this is all the information she
needs
I'm enjoying this this feels like the
crew of Wednesday made this episode I
can totally Yeah Yeah Tim Bernie and
direct this one
gloves for blades
I'm not sure where he gets these ideas
about his clothes talk about the super
speed we're looking for a fugitive goes
by the name of Luffy I have one of the
staff members keeping an eye on now
ooh the Marines are here they've come to
collect the drunken strawhead pirate
bring him to the front of the house at
once oh I guess just the snail
communication is just the the thing
everyone uses yeah I think it's just
yeah it's just phones in this world
interesting there's nothing I can do
at least Luffy is walking again
damn
it's like someone got hit in the face
with a frying pan
foreign
factor or super strength
backstory that's what I'm talking about
I know the one who died who would care
so much about
God I would love to do Kendo
is that a different actor oh [__] yeah
oh looks just like him
oh you're dropping your elbow
there's also a lover
I'm the best fighter here other than you
I'm gonna surpass you then I'm gonna be
the world's greatest swordsman but not
today well
[Music]
what's five real blades to Sue's best
guitarist
you want to beat me you better be ready
to kill me
or I like her
I wouldn't be yelling at her
I don't know how to express my feelings
hurry up Let Me In believe me
he's gonna tell her the whole truth and
then the real truth and she's not gonna
believe any of it you know she's
probably gonna be like I know your
stories are all made up we can have no
don't call Claude he's the one trying to
hurt you kill Mary
for the money
he wants your money everybody wants my
money I believed your stories because
they were fun
lock the house down
oh fancy
oh what an interesting design that's
cool that's really cool interesting
oh that's really neat
quite disconcerting
my parents built him to keep the Pirates
up
but now there it's in you gotta believe
now
hey
why wouldn't we be alive because because
of the same story
man the way they transition to these
split screens oh fun outfits right share
little bunny ears you got a half mask
oh Edward Scissor Hands
they're only a three-person crew if we
stay here we die we have to leave
I am your friend
this guy is scary especially with his
lighting
creepy your friends are all gone
it's just you and me Miss Kaya I love
how much fun he's having oh yeah so
devilish are you sure maybe there's
another way this is the only option we
have to go
[Music]
do you believe in round
oh that's great yeah it was so Sinister
yeah it's a great reveal he knows he got
her
foreign
I was just gonna say that
you learn your lesson not in this
lifetime
send this
such a fun show man
she have the white sword she does
okay okay
this dude needs two swords she is badass
she's better
[Music]
swordplay choreography is phenomenal on
this show
ah
fascinating I really love that they
brought this like Shogun vibe to life
yeah right so cool
interesting parallel
[Music]
you must relive this memory all the time
you'll surpass me in size
strength
and speed eventually he'll surprise me
and everything feels like there's like a
burst of emotions waiting to come out of
her the way she communicates all the
boys will get taller
stronger their arms
we'll have to join the WNBA girls can be
boys but no woman can beat a man whoa
you're my goal if you just give up when
has all our training been for let's
fight every day we'll keep getting
better and stronger until one of us
becomes the greatest oh
do that for me
or whatever
thought a fight train and kick your butt
every single day that's sweet
about a fight
train
kick your butt
every single day
that's really cool one of us should
become the world's greatest swords or
woman to ever live
kinship kinship love that's a very
different dynamic I think that's so cool
they brought that Gart doesn't believe
in you he's using you you're just
jealous
you got something to say
oh
big creepy room no problem
well there's like a full-on horror
episode
you think of me be so disappointed I
mean he physically weakened you which
makes it harder to keep your awareness
up
did get out of that house
it's not as scary with the lights on
that keeps me walking down the same
hallway
right he's just pacing
hyping himself up
[Music]
I am very invested in this story I'm so
curious to know exactly what happened to
her because that must have been her like
with the candles when we first met him
it's honoring her
um yeah maybe that's what I'm thinking
yeah seven years ago somebody just goes
there to honor her every year or
something it was an accident
she's gone what was the accident she's
not dead I didn't see no body she's
gonna come back in episode 407.
I mean she must be dead if there is able
to get her sword or she was like you
must leave this place because Zoro was
the chosen one and we can't have you
interfering with his progress there is
no body yeah it's definitely still out
there 100 yeah
oh nice like that picture
black and white with the blue hair they
had Photoshop back then
sensei
please give me the honor of allowing me
to carry queen of sword
you are worthy man and that's the sword
that's gonna get you out
Queen Anne I made a promise that one of
us
become the world's greatest swordsman to
ever live
thanks great she's not dead I wonder if
they got rid of her because they were
afraid that
the result I talk about her being a
woman yeah like you can't let a woman
become the ultimate sorcerer so I don't
know
you're becoming too powerful must be
exiled Kobe
I gotta go back the butler he's gonna
kill Kaya I think he's gonna go after my
crew I want to direct orders to bring
you in I already piece all that together
good question
I just had an allergic reaction
he drank and gave him a visit
start walking pirate or die
hey there's our boy give him another
haircut
hahaha
yes Kobe I know you've got a job to do
damn he's got gray hair
[Laughter]
but I'm gonna go back and help my
friends so don't try to stop me I'll be
so good man movie's my favorite that
fluctuates
they're just perfect together
sounds like we have a bigger rap problem
than I thought
I'll never find you there oh now Kaya
I know you're in here
no point in hiding
shrill
when all I wanted to do was it rip your
tongue out
oh Jesus no you didn't consider this
Payback
for all those years
listen to your incessant why do villains
ever monologue in rooms where the people
aren't there
thank you
this is really cool his Earl must be
strong if you just lifted that thing out
by himself
it's got to have that durability his
weakness is in the back of his head
though maybe because he was intoxicated
too
maybe you always want daddy's little
girl even if he didn't have enough time
for you
don't just pop out don't just pop out
don't do it he's begging you on
or that fast
yeah yeah you're dumb you're dumb
foreign
[Music]
yeah but he's choosing not to because we
got to keep some main characters alive
[Laughter]
awesome maybe this time we keep his
swords
[Music]
fantastic
oh great hope that work holy [__] that
was awesome nice
[Music]
I love I love this the Dual choreography
of them too great fight
these are my friends
[Laughter]
you don't get to mess with them
this is a really awesome episode yeah
someone's always waiting to Slit your
throat Pirates
why even your own crew no he's like
throwing his voice across from him he's
got each other's backs
until the day they don't I've killed
more crewmates than I care to remember
they're Expendable oh you looked
actually scared
[Music]
they don't have fangs
oh you [__] oh wow
screw you
oh no you didn't
that's our girl sword you better put
some respect on it they sure knows how
to put a lot of great emphasis on
meaningful items you gave up on your
dream
no one who does that can ever call
themselves a pirate I like how this
villains try to make him feel
disillusioned by the whole pirate
Journey he's been on I think that's
really smart yeah conflict with this
goal the question is confidence right so
I can guess himself
yes focus Luffy
yeah he's just falling asleep no
[Music]
no yes
it's so animated dude I know it's great
I didn't plan for that
picture
[Music]
heroic music God the wire work is great
that's so cool
oh my God amazing amazing yeah so good
it's actually him yeah no
oh man
I don't think these guys are going to be
this capable all right I feel like
they've been out of the game for a long
time
three years at least right there yeah
they've been chilling
finish them Zorro
[Music]
nice yes
so I guess he can move fast but he can't
strike fast I guess so
nice
[Music]
damn this actor is great
oh my God
[Music]
he's a different kind of pirate
[Laughter]
now I bet that other guy is gonna
recruit him to be part of his thing now
they're all gonna try to fight Luffy we
have to get out of here where are we
going to go we don't even have a ship
yes you do she owes you one yes
you do they did a lot to earn that ship
it was all big ruse
[Laughter]
whenever you're riding the shipyard off
to my parents past
my oldest companion I hereby name this
ship the go and Mary
foreign
just come on already hmm
I'm gonna need a great Sharpshooter just
like yeah so there's no oh the woman he
loves though
I said I'd never leave you I think I
might do something different study to
become a doctor oh that's different okay
can sometimes I expect here over the
past real Adventures
they do know I'm the captain right
interracial love
[Laughter]
wow what an intricate design wow so cool
and we'll be sitting on the top right
there nice it's cool because like I'm
sure for fans of the anime and they're
mango it's like oh they got the shift to
life but even without having been
familiar with it they still imbue this
with so much meaning behind the ship
that even when he gets it it's like yeah
that's awesome yeah it's super rewarding
this guy looks so familiar I'm pretty
sure there's just like a little bit of
Prosthetics on his face
and get Lucy that's okay son don't be
too hard on yourself you did exactly
what you were supposed to do he was
being used yep the real lesson here
always have a backup plan you flush them
out son
accomplished oh that's intense I made us
a new Jolly Roger for the ship
I am you just got there
oh my God you're laughing hey from now
on
it's all gonna be smooth sailing wow
right
immediately Marines we're under attack
get your sword Zorro
damature ship battle
ground oh
wait wait a minute
holy [__] yo what
I just realized that's the first time
they've seen each other they've seen him
whoa
[Music]
oh damn Grandpa Grandpa papa papa
but he's not
black or Latino they have the same
accent
does it do they I think so
yeah I know he's just he just
light-skinned Latin man Latino
Latino's Mexican but I'm also factoring
the little boy who played young
the guy who plays older Luffy is Mexican
he's Mexican but apparently what's young
Luffy though
ambiguous I found out that apparently
parents won't release the ethnicity
but apparently in the
a friend told me in the actual anime
that Luffy is actually supposed to be
Brazilian
one of my guesses no I didn't say
Brazilian I was getting I thought it but
I was like
I didn't no I didn't express it no
but yeah no
fascinating
oh man this is a good one man I enjoyed
the two-parter that is my favorite one
yeah yes everyone so far you got to dive
into your boys Orioles backstory you got
to see like why that sword so
significant to him
got to got to get a different flavor the
thing I liked that was really cool is
the fact that you know we watched these
back to back and the fact that the first
part of it had a very different tone
from the second part of it because as
you after you said the Tim Burton thing
I started to see a lot of the Wednesday
influences come into it and yeah they
didn't use that that uh that weird
fish lens thing uh in this this past
episode but yeah I like how Zorro and
Luffy kind of got more to do in this one
and
yeah the cool thing about Luffy with the
thing that I think that's
he's endearing and he's
oh he's he's endearing and he's like
this uh this joyful guy but when stuff
gets to the fan or hits the fan he can
be really serious really intense and I
like that aspect about him I think it's
really cool
um I like Zorro's whole thing about
being able to see his backstory and kind
of overcome and then like all the fight
scenes were really incredible and losing
using uh sound against the villain was
really dope yeah yeah man I I had fun I
had a lot of fun with this one
I thought this one was great I think
they didn't I think the purpose now of
that kind of
uh disconcerting lens choice in the
beginning of the third episode
was due to us kind of cluing I said that
the reality we're stepping into is a
false reality you know to kind of make
it look like a little bit Elusive and
dreamlike and then you walk in there and
it's all like beautiful and gorgeous and
everything's just so plentiful all plays
like a dream
and then this is like the harsh dark
nightmare reality that they're actually
succumbing to when the ultimate plan is
revealed and it's all overtaking
what's her name Mary Kate Mary and
Ashley
the girl I don't the blonde girl God
damn it she's so good too she was great
she's great yeah I keep forgetting her
name
um yeah I I I thought this whole episode
was great it was really Sinister I love
the guy who plays the main villain uh in
this one the main pirate villain because
he is such a devilish charm to him and
he's chewing up the scenery but he he
has such a great embodiment of it and I
thought he was so fun he's always been
my favorite antagonist to watch so far
there's like you know it has some of
those villain choices of I don't get why
you just didn't stab him I don't get why
you're just gonna kill him yeah and
there are parts of you know of the rules
of his speed that were kind of
questionable to me like okay you can run
fast but you can't like strike fast you
know and so things like that were kind
of popping up into my brain but I'm like
yeah whatever uh I I'll push to the side
there's there's so small in comparison
to the fact that I'm like nah it's just
such a fun adventure of what we're
watching and uh yeah I agree with you on
the on the whole Luffy um observations
you're making because when he does get
serious like there is a relief when he's
around there is a there is a hope when
he's around
um but I love how he's so constant in
his belief system as well that even when
he's trying to sway him and get into his
head the villain about you know what a
pirate life is really like
that you know Luffy you're just kind of
living in this Fantasy Realm that you
can't you can't assuage him he's going
to stay constant in his belief system
and I still will outsmart and come out
on top with this positiveness and then
with uh Zorro yeah and seeing the
backstory there was really interesting
and it felt very samurai-esque which I
loved and it just seems like with other
anime I've seen as well you know she's
probably alive no dead body no
explanation nope
um She's Gone
yeah knowing the show is [__] forever
uh I can imagine that she comes out
alive in the end in some big reveal and
the question is as to why and I don't
know there did seem to be I don't know
if it was just like an interesting
Nuance to provide with her talking about
which is like lamenting the pain of of
what she feels is inevitable about
as yeah they're they're still teenagers
now but when they're like full-grown
adult women and man they they just
naturally through physicality you will
dominate me and that belief system that
she holds I thought that was a really
interesting conversation uh that they
were having an inverter kind of just
vanished in the next scene right
um I feel like there's something to that
I don't know I might just be reading too
much into it or they just had a
well-nuanced commentary that they
infused and that was just that because
I'm like why would I get rid of her or
why would she like switch to the dark
side or I don't know you know I'm not
sure what it is
um but I I really did love uh all that
and agree the action's great but I
thought like the way this was shot too
but I think like there's a compliment so
well with the way the first episode was
shot where it was like bright and
Fantastical and this one was again a
do us not Ascension descending into a
nightmare
and and watching still a lot of
distorting of of One's Own reality
especially with the the main girl
um whose name I obviously can't remember
but she's brilliant she was she was
great like what the show did a great job
of doing it like this was one episode I
would not have cared as much about her
but I really cared about her by the time
we got to this this point in the story I
was really like oh I'm I'm endeared to
you and I I don't want you to die that
when she decided to run out I was like
what if he gets to jump on her and stabs
her yeah yeah and I think what the show
does a great job at doing it it seems
like they're really building up for
Zorro to fight him and not Luffy to
fight him and then they they switch that
around which I thought might have been
disappointing but I actually thought it
was really rewarding it was a nice
surprise and like Luffy's hand shows up
to save the day I thought that was a a
good flip on what when the one playing
with expectations of the scene yeah no I
agree and yeah the fight fights were
amazing seeing Luffy do his thing and
like okay stretchy powers can work we've
come a long way from the the Tim sale or
was it Tim sales Tim's story Fantastic
Four I think I totally make kamalacan
work with the with the stretchy arms and
stuff sometimes there's a little
questionable I worked for me I loved it
I love the show yeah I love the stretch
yeah no I think this looks better yeah I
think this looks like the best because
like you're just looking at his skin too
yeah you know whereas it's not like he's
not covered in a suit to try to hide it
like you're just you're watching
literally just this flesh expand and it
looks real it looks believable yeah you
know
yeah no I think I like the the crew
coming together and like kind of how you
were saying earlier on how it's even
though we haven't seen the anime it's
really rewarding to watch them finally
get their ship and like yeah they're
really going on this journey to slowly
becoming these Pirates these
non-conventional like pirates for good
essentially yeah uh and yeah I'm excited
to see you know what what that Journey
entails for them like are they gonna get
bounties on their heads are they gonna
add to their crew War
what yeah what in what ways are they
going to be challenged like morally and
then and physically and obviously
there's a crew of people or a larger
threat that's going to be coming into
play pretty soon here and you know how
they're going to overcome that you know
okay stretches away at anything I think
with this show is doing an excellent job
at doing too
is keeping it an ensemble
truly being an ensemble yeah
and yet still constantly keeping Luffy
as the centerpiece as the main thrusts
of inspiration on the journey that are
going on where the crew naturally feels
like they're becoming a crew like when
he's like still saying I'm the captain
of the ship and you can still see how
Nami and Zoro would still be following
him even though there's like a lot of
times you might not be focusing on Luffy
for a good portion of like these two
episodes there's a good portion you're
not with Luffy right for a lot of it
but you still I get like such substance
and quality of scenes with Luffy that
when he's around and certain
interactions and things he says and does
you you still buy into yeah he is
definitely still the lead and he's he's
still the main source of inspiration for
everything that is the glue that ties us
all together you know
um I think it's doing an excellent
excellent job at that where I'm never
feeling like Zoro should be the lead of
the show you know I'm never feeling
anything of that regard uh it's a great
Ensemble [__] fantastic uh yeah guys
uh what did you think about these
two-parter episodes leave your thoughts
down below
um thank you so much for being here had
a great time
and hey
[Music]
got a little bit of time so let's do a
picture of the day shout out Chase
Gardner gonna shout you out today buddy
because we posted our full-length
Reaction watch along over on patreon and
for all the people who qualify for a
page for the day shout out you're the
only one who commented even though we
got a bunch of comments there
I'm a one-piece anime fan this live
action series looks like fun the first
episode was a surprise everything made
for the show was great and the cast
looks amazing is what he said I've only
seen the first episode for Netflix live
action one piece well I'm sure by this
point you have already finished this
[__]
Chase I hope that you are having a great
time with this show Aaron freestyle a
poem for him would you
Chase man watching One Piece
doing it on his own time
I like to do my things make my own
Rhymes Chase you're a gardener making
things grow
y'all here making free comments letting
words flow you already know
too late shout outs done it's time to go
deuces
mic drop
[Music]
okay
why did you say that
I was like I was just
you don't like it
I didn't I never I never said those
words
[Laughter]
all right Greg has a freestyle
[Music]